[Musique]
tout d'abord parce que l'accès aux
droits nous tient à cœur et
particulièrement important et puis
c'était aussi une manière d'acculturer
un peu
de public au droit en plus nous avons
décidé de prendre l'aspect
environnemental qui est aussi un aspect
qui nous tient à cœur
[Musique]
nous retrouvons à partir de 20 heures à
l'espace mojit Maurice Béjart il y aura
d'abord la projection du film darkwater
qui est un film de sott Ace ou un avocat
spécialisé dans la défense des
industries chimiques va devoir combattre
pour défendre l'environnement et puis à
la suite de ce film il y aurait une
confiance débat animée par Maître
François de Cambier et Philippe assoup
vous n'avez pas compris je suis avocat
d'affaires donc je défends les
entreprises de chimie maintenant vous
allez me défendre
vous en avez perdu combien
190 vous avez perdu 190 vaches vous
allez pas me dire que c'est normal vous
aussi
c'est juste une petite affaire pour un
ami de la famille et au moins on aura
aidé quelqu'un le firmier ou toi c'est
les produits chimiques qui font ça je
comprends pas tout dans leurs archives
on nous cache des choses
[Musique]
et nous avons eu plusieurs idées et nous
avons fini par choisir ce film en fait
le thème sous-jacent ici c'était à
droite et environnement donc nous
voulions un film habilet d'eux par
ailleurs c'est un très bon film suivi en
plus d'une conférence des pas animée par
François de cambiere qui a déjà animé
des conférences d'états sur ce film ce
qui faisait que c'est vraiment très
pertinent en l'occurrence
système est truqué ils veulent nous
faire croire qu'il nous protège